ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLLY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL I AGREE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU GEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES LARA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY V. LEVINE
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THE SYRIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON P. THREE
NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS
RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TANE
MELENDEZ VIA FOOD WA VOEPEL
WALDRON. LORD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND- IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THIS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN THE
MONEY IS HERE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE QT
MERCIFUL. OH GOD. YOUR GRACE
SUSTAINS US THROUGHOUT EVERY
DIFFICULTY AND SUPPLIES OUR
NEEDY HARKS WITH ENCOURAGEMENT.
GIVE US WISDOM FOR THE WORK
THAT IS BEFORE US. COM OUR
ATTITUDES BLESSED US WITH
STRENGTH TO DO THE WORK OF THIS
NEW DAY THAT YOU HAVE BLESSED
US WITH. I MEAN. THANK YOU MOM
IS HERE YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER BIGELOW THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. ZERO AND- IT IS.
FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. GOLDEN ONE
CENTER SACRAMENTO MONDAY
DECEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
PURSUANT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE HOUR OF
TWELVE O'CLOCK THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO REGULAR SESSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WAS
CALLED TO ORDER BY C. PARKER
JEFF FLOCK OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION THE CONFORMITY
WITH THE LAW THE FOLLOWING
OFFICES WERE ALSO PRESENT AB
LEADS MINUTE CLERK LISA BUCKLEY
SHE STARTED AT ARMS. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
READING DAY WITH A WOMAN
READING LOCAL WHICH CORRECTIVE
READING RECALL VOTE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF ROLES GOLD
FROM ANSWERS THE NAME I AGREE
ARAMBULA VALUES ANYWAY IS- AND-
WALDRON. THAT THE READING OF
PREVIOUS DAY JOURNAL BE. WITH
PRESIDENT. AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEGAN DALLY. FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER.
AND FOR FUNERAL AND DEATH IN
THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JIM
COOPER.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THIS IS PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. MS RAMOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
pASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF THE ONE OF
THE GARCIA GIPSON JONES SAWYER
AND PETRIE-NORRIS TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ORDER H. R. THIRTEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA TO THE THIRD READING
FILE. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THE
CLERK WILL NOTE THAT MISTER
RAMOS WILL ALSO BE SPEAKING ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. AND MEMBERS SPEAKING OF
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY AT THIS TIME WE- ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP SOME
BUDGET RELATED ITEMS IN THE TEN
O'CLOCK HOUR. SO WE ARE GOING
TO. RESHUFFLE. THE DECK ON THE
ORDER OF ACTIVITIES TODAY WE
ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AT THIS
TIME. AND MEMBERS I WOULD ASK.
PER THE USUAL PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS AT THIS TIME FOR GERMANS
TO MEMORY OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW BE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS RAN A
PREPARATION IS BEGINNING GERMAN
AND MEMORY MISTER GIBSON IN THE
WELL OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO **** BODY TO ADJOURN. IN THE
MEMORY OF CHARLES PRINCE IN
BETTER KNOWN AS THE- CARLOS.
THE- CARLOS WAS BORN IN LOS
ANGELES WHEN OCTOBER FIFTEENTH.
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR. HE LED
HIS LIFE FILLED WITH TRAVEL
ADVENTURE AND MOST OF ALL HE
FOUGHT FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. HE OFTEN SHARED
THOUGHTS OF GROWING UP IN A
CHALLENGING HOUSEHOLD HE ALWAYS
FOUND HOPE. IN A POSITIVE LIGHT
WITH THE PAINS OF GROWING UP AT
EARLY AGE LATER IN LIFE HE
JOINED THE TEAMSTERS LOCAL SIX
NINETY TWO IN LONG BEACH AND
AIDED IN NEGOTIATIONS IN UNION
CONTRACT WITH TRUCK COMPANIES
TRUCKING COMPANIES. THE- CARLOS
WITH THE UNION MAN AND PROUD OF
IT HE SUPPORTED EFFORTS OF
ORGANIZING DRIVERS PICKET LINES
MOBILIZING COMMUNITY TO SUPPORT
LABOR JUSTICE. NOTABLE
CAMPAIGNS INCLUDES PORTRAIT
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS SPEAKING IN
DEFENSE OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
SUCH AS CATSKILL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. AND STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH EDUCATORS
DURING UT LA UNITED TEACHERS
LOS ANGELES STRIKE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN THE-
CARLOS BECAME A MENTOR TO ALL
IN HIS COMMUNITY. HE GAVE YOU
SOUND ADVICE WHETHER YOU WANT
IT OR NOT IT CAME FROM THE
HEART. LIFE EXPERIENCES AS WELL
AS TRIBULATIONS. ON WEDNESDAY
DECEMBER THE NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY DEAL CARLOS PASSED AWAY.
PEACEFULLY IN HIS SLEEP AT
NIGHT. ACCORDING TO HIS LOVED
ONES HE SPENT THE DAYS OF HIS
LIFE IN SERVICE TO OTHERS.
ENCOURAGING AND INSURING HIS
LOVED ONES BE SAFE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND OF COURSE HE DID
HIS CHORES. HE LEAVES BEHIND
MANY FRIENDS LOVED ONES
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THE- CARLOS WAS A
GREAT FRIEND TO ME AS WELL AS A
MENTOR TO ME HE PARTICIPATED IN
ALL COMMUNITY EVENTS THAT I HAD
IN THE DISTRICT. HOSTED MANY
EVENTS HIMSELF AND PROVIDED KEY
INFORMATION TO THE HARBOR
COMMUNITY AND WILMINGTON. HIS
WISDOM AND ACTIVISM WILL EVER
LIVE ON HE WILL BE MISSED.
COLLEAGUES ASK YOUR JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND WE
CALL THEM UNCLE CARLOS THE-
CARLOS. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR A GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ARRIVED
TODAY TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
BILLS OF CHEAP BENITEZ WHO
WE'VE LOST ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SIX. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
COPA NINETEEN. YOUR A WELL
RESPECTED TRIBAL LEADER AND
RETIRED CHAIRMAN OF THE CABAZON
BAND OF THE WEEK IN. JOSEPH OR
JOE. WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
TO SUSIE MIKE AND FOUR INCH OF
ALASKA'S AT THE SABOL BUT
INDIAN HOSPITAL IN SAN A SIMPLE
CALIFORNIA. SHE ENITEZ GREW UP
FROM THE HOMELESS OF BEGINNINGS
ON AND UNDERSERVED UNDEVELOPED
RESERVATION. HE WAS PROUD TO BE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE. TRAINED AS
AN ATHLETE AND ENJOYED MAKING
FRIENDS WHEREVER HE WENT.
REALLY A PERSONALITY TRAIT HE
CARRIED ALL HIS LIFE. HE QUICK
TASKS LIKE RUNNING TO THE STORE
FOR A GALLON OF MILK. WAS NEVER
TOO QUICK FOR JOBS ONE OF THOSE
TRAITS AND PERSONALITIES THAT
HE CARRIED THROUGHOUT HIS
LEADERSHIP AT THE TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN. HE COULD NOT GO
WITHOUT RUNNING INTO AN OLD
FRIEND OR MAKING NEW ONES
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE LIFE. HE
MARRIED AND HAD A SON WITH HIS
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART GAIL
EMILY. FORTUNATELY GALLAGHER
SEATED HIM IN DEATH. BUT LOVE
FOUND JOE AGAIN. HE MET HIS
WIFE DIANA AND HER TWO CHILDREN
THAT MAKE MAN'S FURNITURE STORE
VERY POPULAR PLACE IN MY
DISTRICT. THEY MARRIED ON HIS
BIRTHDAY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE AND TOGETHER THEY WELCOMED
A NEW DAUGHTER. AS TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN OF THE CABAZON BAND OF
CAHUILLA INDIANS HE LET HIS
TRIED TO PROSPERITY. JOE WAS.
EVER GENEROUS WITH HIS TIME
LOVE AND ATTENTION. HE WAS AN
ELDER AT ST ANDREW PRESBYTERIAN
CHURCH AND IT ALSO FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY MUSEUM. G.
BENITEZ VOLUNTEERED FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB. NATIVE AMERICAN LAND
CONSERVANCY CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
INDIAN HOW THE NATIONAL BORDER
MILLION OUT FISH FOOD BANK JOB
I HIGH SCHOOL ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION. OUR BRAVE
SPIRITUAL WATER FOUGHT THE
TOUGHEST PHYSICAL BATTLE OF HIS
LIFE AGAINST COVERT NINETEEN.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DIANA. SONS MARC MICHAEL
DAUGHTERS LISA TRACY AND
CHILDREN MARCY SABRINA RECOUNT
ROBERT JUNIOR AND ABOUT A- SHE
BELIEVE THIS WAS A TRAILBLAZER
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY WHO WILL
BE REMEMBERED. FOR HIS LEGACY
SERVICE WE WILL MISS HIM DEARLY
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A PERSONAL
STORY. AND FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THE CAPITAL FOR MANY
MANY YEARS ON THE STOP SIGN.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE CABAZON
BAND OF CAHUILLA INDIANS IT IS
A TRY. HE HAS- SHAKING THINGS
UP ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHEN IT
COMES TO TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
THEM AND THE MORONGO TRIBE- THE
DRIVES THAT LED THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT TO SET PRECEDENT.
FOR THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT THAT ULTIMATELY
LED TO TRIBAL GAMING BEING
SOLIDIFIED IN THIS COUNTRY. I
THINK ARE CALLING FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE COULD PROBABLY
SPEAK BETTER TO THE HISTORY OF
THAT THAN I CAN BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT AS A- YOUNG TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD INTERN FOR THE CABAZON
BAND OF CAHUILLA INDIANS I
RECALL. WALKING THE HALLS OF
THIS CAPITAL AND WHEN PEOPLE
KNEW THAT WE WERE HERE WITH
CABAZON BAND OF. MISSION
INDIANS AND WHETHER YOU WERE
WITH- CHAIRMAN BENITEZ AND THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS TEAMS OR
OTHER TRIBAL MEMBERS- PEOPLE IN
THESE HALLS PEOPLE IN THESE
OFFICES. WOULD LISTEN. AND
GERMAN BENITEZ WAS THE
SPIRITUAL ELDER OF THE TRIBE
THE ONE PERSON THAT AS A YOUNG
PERSON WE WOULD GO TO AN- HEAR
ABOUT STORIES FROM THE PAST
THAT. THINGS FOR TRIBES AT
LEAST THE CABAZON BAND WORK
ALWAYS WHAT THEY WERE TO BE AT
THE MOMENT I TRIED THAT
STRUGGLED SIGNIFICANTLY TO GET
ON THEIR FEET AND TAKE CARE OF
THEIR PEOPLE- ON THEIR
RESERVATION AND CONTRIBUTE. TO
MANY CAUSES IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
BE GOOD NEIGHBORS- GOOD
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIPS- EVERY NOW AND
THEN MR. BENITEZ WOULD TEACH ME
A WORD OR TWO IN COULD WE- AND
IT WASN'T UP UNCOMMON THAT I'D
RUN INTO HIM AT THE STARBUCKS
AND PATELLA. PRIOR TO CALL THE
NINETEEN AND I COULD WALK IN.
AND SAY HELLO TO HIM IN HIS
NATIVE LANGUAGE AND I WALK IN
AND SAY GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND I WOULD SAY- MA'AM WHEN.
AND THAT MEANS HELLO IN IN
KOREA AND AT SOME POINT HE SAID
TO ME. HAVING TO LEARN ANY NEW
WORDS. MR GARCIA. AND I WOULD
STOP TO THINK INTO WILL WELL
YEAH HE DID TEACH ME A FEW
OTHER WORDS. AND THEN I WOULD
SAY- MEN MALE LANGUAGES HELLO
TO YOU TOO. RIGHT AS THE HE
RESPONDED TO ME- CHAIRMAN
BENITEZ- WILL BE DEARLY MISSED
NOT JUST BY HIS FAMILY- THE
MEMBERS OF THIS TRIBE- THE
ORGANIZATIONS ANY VOLUNTEER
WITH BY INDIAN COUNTRY- THE
PROCESS NATION. HE WAS A GREAT
LEADER- FOR ALL OF US AN
EXAMPLE- TO FOLLOW AND- FOR ME
AS A YOUNG PERSON I WAS
GRATEFUL TO HAVEMET HIM AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THAT HE
OPENED UP FOR ME AND MANY
OTHERS IN OUR COMMUNITY TURN OF
ALL TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN OUR TRIBAL NATIONS IN
OUR ADJACENT COMMUNITIES-
PASSED AWAY DURING HIS NAME.
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA AND MR RAMEAU'S WHO WERE
ALSO RECOGNIZED ON THIS A
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE COACHELLA
VALLEY FOR A HONORING- CHAIRMAN
JOE BENITEZ IN THE MEMORY. THAT
HE HAS INSTILLED IN INDIAN
COUNTRY AND THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY THE COACHELLA VALLEY
AREA MY COLLEAGUE TALKS ABOUT
THE TIME. WHEN LOBBYING WAS
TAKING PLACE WHERE THERE WAS NO
GAMING THERE WAS NO RIGHTS THAT
WERE THERE AND PROTESTS WERE
BEING HELD. AND IT WAS CABEZON
THAT FILED A CASE AND MORONGO
CAME FORWARD. THERE WAS ALSO A
PROTEST OVER TAKING PLACE WHERE
THERE IS- PLANS TO SHUT DOWN
THE TEN FREEWAY- AND ONE THAT
CAME FORWARD. THEN THE
NEGOTIATIONS STARTED TO HAPEN
SO THERE'S NO STRANGER TO
LEADERS LIKE GERMAN JOB ANITA'S
PAVING THE WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT VOICE IS BEING HEARD. AND
MANY OF THE TOPICS THAT WE'RE
STILL DEBATING HERE ON THIS
FLOOR I RESONATE WITH THOSE
TYPES OF A PEACEFUL ACTIONS-
CHAIRMAN JOE BENITEZ. WAS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CABAZON OF
PEOPLE BUT ALSO- HIS BLOODLINE
HAS GENERAL LEVY BLOOD IN IT
AND HE HAS RELATIVES THAT ARE
NOW- CHAIR. OF THE TWENTY NINE
PALMS BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN GERMANY THIS- WAS SOME OF
THE COULD SEE INTO THE FUTURE
ONE. MAKING SURE THAT WE
PRESERVE THE RIGHTS FOR GAMING
SO THEN WE WOULD HAVE THE
INCOME TO BE ABLE TO TACKLE THE
OTHER ISSUES. THE SO
DRASTICALLY STILL AFFECT OF
MAJORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE THROUGH EDUCATION
THROUGH CULTURE THROUGH HISTORY
OF WHO WE TRULY ARE AS
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE SO MUCH SO
THAT IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE
STARTED THE TRIBAL UNITY. IN
CULTURAL AWARENESS PROGRAMME
FROM THE SENATE WHY DIDN'T
RESERVATIONS AND TWENTY NINE
PAMS ON CHANNEL WHERE THE
INDIANS AND- A GERMAN BENITEZ
WAS PART OF THAT AND REALLY
WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU GO TO THE
ELDERS OF THOSE AREAS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND ASK FOR THEIR
BLESSING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THOSE PROGRAMS. AND CHAIRMAN
BENITO WAS RIGHT THERE WILL US
THROUGHOUT THAT YEAR FROM
NINETY SIX AND EVEN UP TO NOW.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING THAT WAY IN
INSTILLING IN THE COMMUNITY THE
EDUCATION OF WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE. IN
WITH MOVING FORWARD ON THAT THE
VENTURE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
THE SALT SONGS CAME BACK TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE JAM ALEVIS AND
THEY'RE STILL NOW THEY'RE BEING
SONG. ON AT THOSE DIFFERENT
EVENTS AND CEREMONIES THAT ARE
THERE. THIS CHAIRMAN LIKE
GIOVANNI THIS AND MANY OTHERS
NOW THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ON THIS LEGISLATIVE
FLOOR. THAT I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SPEAKER AND
ALL THSE THAT ARE HERE NOW
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A TIME
COMING. WHERE IN THE PAST WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HONOR
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WITH
THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND REALLY IN HIGH REGARD TO
CHAIRMAN JOE BENITEZ AND HIS
WORK NOT ONLY IN INDIAN COUNTRY
FOR ECONOMIC SUCCESS. BUT THE
HISTORY AND THE REPAYMENT OF
THE CULTURE OF WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. HIS
KNOWLEDGE WILL BE SORELY MISSED
THROUGHOUT ALL OF INDIAN
COUNTRY. I RISE IN. A IN AN
AGREEMENT WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY. TO
HAVE A MEMORIAL IN HIS NAME.
HERE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ROMMEL'S. M. MEMBERS
GESTURE REMIND YOU WE WILL BE
TAKING UP BUDGET BILLS A COUPLE
OF BUDGET ITEMS IN THE TEN
O'CLOCK HOUR WE ARE NOW AT THE
GERMAN O MEMORY THE QUORUM
CALL IS STILL IN PLACE AT THIS
TIME. I WOULD LIKE RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE JONES
SAWYER. FOR HIS GERMAN MEMORY
MISTER JONES SAWYER. YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF LESLIE HAGEN MORGAN
AND EDUCATOR COMMUNITY ACTIVIST.
BUT ONE OF THE DELEGATES TO THE
FIFTY NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SOMEONE WHO RAN AGAINST ME IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. DIE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AT THE TENDER AGE
OF THIRTY EIGHT. HE WAS RAISED
BY A SINGLE MOTHER WHO
EMIGRATED FROM GHANA LEARN SHE
LESLIE LEARN THE VALUE OF AN
EDUCATION AND HARD WORK AS HE
WATCHED HIS MOTHER ATTEND
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND BECOME A NURSE.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL LESLIE MOVED TO ATLANTA
TO EARN HIS BACHELOR'S IN
GLOBAL STUDIES FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WEST GEORGIA.
NOTING THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION HE WENT ON TO EARN
HIS MASTER'S IN GOVERNMENT FROM
HARVARD UNIVERSITY. SHORTLY
AFTER HE AND HIS WIFE RESIDE IN
TEXAS FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
HOWEVER AFTER MOVING BACK TO
HIS HOMETOWN IN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FOUR LET'S SEE POUND
IT CITY OF. AN ORGANIZED
INVASION AIMED AT IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR YOUTH AND
SOUTH LOS ANGELES LEFTY ALWAYS
HAD HIS NEIGHBORHOOD OF SOUTH
LA AT HEART AND KNEW HE WANTED
TO HELP IMPROVE OTHER YOUTH IN
HIS HOME TOWN TOWARD SUCCESS.
NOT ONLY DID LESLIE PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN DEVELOPING CRITICAL
NECESSITIES FOR FOX THE USE HE
ALSO ORGANIZE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING FOR UNDERSERVED
YOUTH TO RECEIVE THE TOOLS TO
EXCEL IN EDUCATION. HAVE YOUTH
LESLIE OVERSAW AND 80%
GRADUATION RATE OF THE STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT THE ORGANIZATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN LESLIE
BECAME THE PROGRAM CALL MORE
COORDINATOR FOR THE MAYOR'S
GANG REDUCTION YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. IN THIS
ROLE. LESLIE ASSISTED IN TRANS.
TRANSITIONING FORMER GANG
MEMBERS INTO EDUCATION
COMMUNITY SERVICE MEMBERS
WITHIN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
ADDITIONAL INITIATIVES LED BY
LESLIE INCLUDED PROVIDING FRESH
FOOD FOR THE COMMUNITY OFFERING
SAFE AFTER SCHOOL SPACE FOR
STUDENTS TO ARTISTICALLY
EXPRESS THEMSELVES AND STEPS IN
ESTABLISHING A PROGRAM TO
CONNECT COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
EMPLOYMENT WITH PROFITABLE
WAGES. LET'S SEE SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE MEDINA PAGAN MORGAN
AND THEIR TWO CHILDREN. LISTEN
LIVE PIES GRANDMA THIS MORALS
WHICH STATED IF YOU'RE BORN
INTO A HOUSE AND A PICTURE
FRAME IS CROOKED. AND YOU
PASSED AWAY IN A FRAME IS STILL
CROOKED YOU FAILED IN LIFE.
LET'S SEE NOT ONLY STRAIGHTEN
THE FRAME IN THE HOUSE HE WAS
BORN INTO HE ALSO HELP
STRAIGHTEN THE FRAMES IN THE
HOUSES OF ALL WHO HE EMPOWERED
WITHIN. THIS COMMUNITY. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE INSURANCE IN
THE MEMORY OF LESLIE HAGEN
MORGAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN A MEMORY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF LINDA
NEARING LAST MONTH I HEARD
EIGHT AS WE LEARN THE NEWS THAT
LINDA NEARING PASSED AWAY AFTER
A LONG HOT BATTLE WITH CANCER.
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A
CARING AND PASSIONATE LEADER IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND IS IT
YOUR FRIEND TO ALL NEW HER.
LINDA NEARING IT'S BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ORANGE COUNTY
POLITICS FOR MANY YEARS.
BUILDING UP A REGISTRATION AND
VOLUNTEER ENGAGEMENT THAT
RESULTED IN AN MATCH BETTER
TURNOUT IN RECENT ELECTIONS.
THE LIST OF WINDOWS MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY
IS LONG. TO NAME A FEW SHE
SERVED AS A LEADER ON THE
DEMOCRATIC FOUNDATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD. AS A DELEGATE TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ANNOUNCED THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
LAGUNA WOODS DEMOCRATIC CLUB
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE. I'M
LUCKY TO NOT ONLY OF KNOWN
LINDA BUT ALSO TO BEEN ABLE TO
CALL HER MY FRIEND. SHE REALLY
WAS A DYNAMO. A DECADES LONG
ADVOCATE OF COMPASSION AND
CHOICES THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION WHICH PROMOTES
DEATH WITH DIGNITY LAWS. AND
ALSO FOUGHT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVES WHICH FINALLY MADE
END OF LIFE OPTIONS POSSIBLE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. FOR PEOPLE WITH
THE SIX MONTH TERMINAL
DIAGNOSIS. DIAGNOSED WITH THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE FORM OF CLEO OF
CUSTOMER. LINDA CHOSE THE END
HER RETURN TO START TEST. HER
INFECTIOUS LAUGH HER OPEN
SPIRIT AND HER BRAVE OPTIMISM
FOR WITH HER UNTIL THE VERY END.
LINDA TO MANY LIVES AND MANY
HEARTS SHE WILL BE MISSED
ENORMOUSLY AND HER MEMORY WILL
LIVE ON FOR YEARS TO COME. MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE OBJECT
TURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
ENGINEERS. THANK YOU THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MEMBERS
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESPERATE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
pAND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
THERE WAS A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT
TO TOMORROW TOMORROW IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS HIS
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING MISTER RAMOS HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED. WITH
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE AND
TAKE UP OUR FIRST BUDGET ITEM-
THE SECOND BUDGET ITEM WE HAVE
TO WAIT UNTIL TEN TWENTY ONE AM
TO TAKE UP BUT WE MAY TAKE UP.
THIS FIRST ITEM. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER. ONE SENATE BILL.
EIGHTY NINE. AND THE CARBURETOR
SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BROTHER BILL.
A AND M'S REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS ITEM. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. SB EIGHTY
NINE MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE BUDGET ACT NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT S. B. NINETY ONE
WHICH CONTAINS THE MAIN
ELEMENTS OF THE EVICTION FROM
PREVENTION PROPOSAL.
SPECIFICALLY SB EIGHTY NINE
GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THE
ABILITY TO TRANSFER FUNDING FOR
ANY CITY THAT WANTS TO POOL
THEIR DIRECT FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH THE NEW
STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RAILS.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM I'M
GOING TO ALLOW A LITTLE EXTRA
TIME. SINCE I ORIGINALLY SAID
WILL BE TAKING THIS UP AT TEN.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM. C.
GARY NOW. WITH THAT WORK OF
WORLD. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIGNER TO VOTE.
YEAH ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED
ABOUT MEMBERS WERE TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT.
AND WITH THAT THE
CLERK. WELL CLOSER ALL. I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
OKAY MEMBERS. MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW GOING TO PROCEED
WITH THE SECOND BUDGET ITEM
BEFORE THE BODY TODAY THIS IS
FILE ITEM. NUMBER TWO. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINETY
ONE. AND THE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL NINETY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
TENNESSEE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. AND MS RACE YOU
MAY- OPEN. THANK MISTER SPEAKER.
THE PANDEMIC HAS CREATED A
MOUNTAIN OF UNPAID RENTAL DEBT
WHICH IS CAUSED INSTABILITY IN
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS FOR BOTH
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS. THIS
BILL AND SB EIGHTY NINE WHICH
WE JUST VOTED ON PROVIDE URGENT
ASSISTANCE TO RENTERS AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME TO STRUGGLING
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE CURRENT EVICTION MORATORIUM
WHICH WAS DUE TO EXPIRE ON
SUNDAY. JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
IT'LL BE EXTENDED NOW UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT ALSO APPROPRIATE AND
ALLOCATES ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. IT SETS REIMBURSEMENT
LEVELS FOR RENTAL RELIEF. IT
EXTENDS THE VARIOUS PROTECTIONS
TO TENANTS RELATING TO UNPAID
RENT DURING THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT CREATES A
PROCESS TO USE A CONTRACTOR
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE NEW
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND
IT REQUIRES REPORTING ON
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE AND
EXPENDITURES. MEMBERS I REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
REYES MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AS
YOU ALL KNOW IN FOUR DAYS THE
CURRENT BECOME MORE TOURING
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE AT THE END
OF LAST SESSION. EXPIRES AND
BASED ON RECENT CENSUS SURVEYS
POSTED TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HAVE STATED THAT THEY HAVE
LITTLE OR NO CONFIDENCE. OF
PAYING NEXT MONTH'S RENT. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S AT STAKE. IN
OTHER STATES WHERE VICTOR MORE
TORRANCE OF EXPIRED. UCLA STUDY
DOCUMENTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL COVERED CASES CLOSE
TO ELEVEN THOUSAND DEATHS. AT
THIS DEADLIEST OF MOMENTS IN
THE PANDEMIC WE CAN'T HAVE
TENANTS PUSHED OUT ON THE
STREETS OR INTO OVERCROWDED
SETTINGS. I WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK LEADERSHIP STARTING
WITH OUR SPEAKER MAJORITY
LEADER SPEAKER STAFF. ARE
HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF THE
SENATE PRESIDENT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ADVOCATES FOR ALL
SIDES. LIKE ALL CHALLENGING
COMPROMISES THIS IS NOT A
PERFECT DEAL BUT IT IS
NECESSARY TO AVOID A DEPICTION
CLIFF. AND TO GET DESPERATELY
NEEDED MONEY BOTH THE
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS QUICKLY. I WANNA TAKE
A MOMENT O THANK THE STATEWIDE
COALITION OF HUNDREDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR TENANTS WHO
SUPPORTED AB FIFTEEN. BECAUSE
OF YOU. NOT ONLY ARE CURRENT
EVICTION PROTECTIONS EXTENDED
THROUGH JUNE. BUT LATE FEES ARE
PROHIBITED. RENTAL THAT CAN'T
BE SOLD THE PREDATORY LENDING
COMPANIES AND OTHER LOOPHOLES
IN EXISTING LAW ARE BEING
CLOSED. WELL SORT OF STATE THE
WITH THIS BILL THE DISCUSSION
IS NOT OVER. WE'RE STILL GOING
TO NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ASSISTTENANTS WHO WILL STILL
HAVE SIGNIFICANT DEBT AFTER
THIS BILL. AND I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF TENANTS ABOUT THE
FACT. THAT THE DEBT RELIEF
ATTENDED CATS IS DEPENDENT ON A
LANDLORDS COOPERATION. WHICH IS
A TROUBLING POWER IMBALANCE. WE
NEED TO AGGRESSIVELY MONITOR
THIS PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL TEND TO BE REALLY FOR
RECEIVING IT. AND I EXPECT THAT
OUR LEGISLATURE WILL LIKELY
NEED TO CONSIDER FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS GAPS IN
THIS BILL AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DEBT RELIEF FOR LOW
INCOME TENANTS. I APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP'S COMMITMENT BOTH TO
AGGRESSIVE MONITORING AND TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
FUTURE ISSUES BEFORE THIS
EXTENSION EXPIRES AT THE END OF
JUNE. IN THE FUTURE. IN
ADDITION TO ASSISTING
STRUGGLING LANDLORDS. WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT NO CALIFORNIA
TENANTS IS AFFECTED. OR SADDLED
WITH LONG TERM DEBT. DUE TO A
PANDEMIC THAT THEY HAD NO
CONTROL OVER. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR TO MR BLOOM. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER BLOOM I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU RETIRED
TO THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
WHILE YOU ARE DOING THAT LET ME
CALL ON MISTER LEE. AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY MR BLOOM IN THE
REAR CHAMBER MISTER LEE. I
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
ONE THOUGH I DO HAVE MY
CONCERNS FIRST I WANT TO
COMMEND THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
HOUSE AS WELL AS THAT OF THE
SENATE TO PRIORITIZE KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS HOUSE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IT SHOWS OUR
COMMITMENT TO WORKING FAMILIES
SINCE THIS IS THE FIRST EARLY
BUDGET ITEM WE TAKE UP. NO ONE
SHOULD LOSE. OKAY NO ONE SHOULD
LOSE THEIR HOME DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AS WE CONTINUE THIS
BATTLE DEFEATING THE VIRUS IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ADOPT
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS SO THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES AS WELL AS PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR SMALL LANDLORDS. THAT MAY
HAVE SUFFERED INCOME LOSS FOR
NEARLY A YEAR NOW. WELL TO
START A SESSION WAS DELAYED
THIS YEAR FOR US WE'RE NOW
FINALIZING THIS BILL FOUR DAYS.
FOUR DAYS BEFORE THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM IS SET TO EXPIRE
THAT'S FOUR DAYS WERE SOME
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS MAY STILL
BELIEVE THE MORATORIUM EXPIRES
ON MONDAY. TENANTS CONTINUE TO
LIVE WITH ANXIETY UNCERTAINTY
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHETHER. OR
NOT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE OR KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD THIS WINTER. AS
ONE OF THE FEW MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE A RENTER. AND
TO NOT OWN ANY PROPERTY OF MY
OWN I UNDERSTAND THIS ANXIETY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
MORE THAN A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEHIND ON RENT
THAT'S NEARLY ONE IN FIVE
RENTERS IN THE FIFTH.
WEALTHIEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
ONE IN FIVE. IN MY HOME COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT
TRANSLATES OVER THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS THAT'S
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS LIVING WITH ANXIETY
OF HOUSING AND SECURITY.
ALTHOUGH HOUSINGINSECURITY AS
AFFECTED COMMUNITIESOF COLOR
LONG BEFORE COVER NINETEEN
APPEARED THIS CURRENT PANDEMIC
AND SUBSEQUENT ECONOMIC COVER
IS DEEPENING THESE INEQUALITIES.
THERE IS SOME LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL NOW WITH THE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ITS PROGRAMMATIC
APPROACH WE CAN WE CAN ACHIEVE
A DEGREE OF STABILITY FOR FEW
MONTHS BOTH RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS. THIS IS A CRUCIAL
URGENCIA FORD BUT OUR WORK IS
FAR FROM OVER. I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT THIS PLAN GIVES
LANDLORDS TOO MUCH POWER IN
ALREADY IN BALLOTS
RELATIONSHIP. AND ULTIMATELY
LEAVES THE FATE OF LOW INCOME
TENANTS IN THE HANDS OF THE
LANDLORD. IN THIS PROPOSAL I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS PROPOSAL IF
A LANDLORD POPS IN OPS
INVOLUNTARILY. THE RECEIPT
PERCENT OF RENT THAT FROM THIS
FUNDING. WHILE THE FOR GO TO
REMAIN 20% IF THE LAND OPS I.
IN A TENT UP. THEN THE RISK ONE
FIVE OR OF RENT TO FOR RENT
THAT FROM THIS. EVEN THOUGH. IN
BOTH CASE ALL MONEY GOES TO THE
LAW. THIS MEANS A OUR LAND TO
SO NOT. TO VOLUNTEER ACCEPT THE
FUNDING THAT IS OFFERED TO THEM.
LOW INCOME TENER RECEIVE 75%
SUPPORT 75% LESS SUPPORT. NOW I
UNDERSTAND THE MOTIVATION IS TO
INCENTIVIZELANDLORDS TO OPT
INTO THE REALLY FUNDS BUT IS
INCUMBENT ON US TO DO MORE TO
PROTECT TAX. FOR STARTERS WE
NEED TO BE ACTIVELY INVOLVING
TENANT GROUPS AND ADVOCATES IN
THE PROCESS AND BRING THEM TO
NEGOTIATION TABLE. TENNIS
GROUPS ARE FRUSTRATED
RIGHTFULLY SO. THEY DO NOT HAVE
AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THEIR INPUTS. TENANTS WHO WE
ARE ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
SHOULD HAVE THEIR VOICE THE
TABLE THEIR VOICES SHOULD BE
HEARD AND THEIR VOICES DESERVE
TO BE HEARD. ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
WE WILL HAVE TO REVISIT THIS
ISSUE BEFORE JUNE THIRTIETH.
THE LOOMING EVICTION CLIFF THE
MOUNTING DEBT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
WILL NOT MAGICALLY RESOLVED
TODAY. AND I FOR ONE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
ON THIS ISSUE WITH THE
INCREDIBLE LEADERS ARE ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP. AND COMMIT TO
MAKING SURE NO ONE LOSES THEIR
HOME DURING THE PANDEMIC. WELL
THIS BILL FAR FROM PERFECT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO
ADDRESSING THIS EVICTION CRISIS
FROM WORSENING OUR HOUSING
CRISIS. I STILL URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK. THANK YOU MR LEE
AND MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO JOIN. IN ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT SB NINETY ONE
AND I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY.
RECOGNIZING THE MEMBERS
LEADERSHIP. AND STAFF BUT
ESPECIALLY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. WHO REALLY GAVE.
NEW MEANING TO THE- OVER USED
TERM WORKING TIRELESSLY- HE'S
PUT IN SO MUCH EFFORT ON THIS
BILL AND THE- OF WEEKS AND
MONTHS PRECEDING THIS DATE- AND
THEY REALLY DESERVES OUR
GRATITUDE. WITH OVER THREE NINE
COVERT CASES AND CAL LAW AND
ALL ROAD TO. ALL CAL. IT GOES
SAYING THAT URGENT OF GETTING
THESE BILLS ON HELP. ON TO ON
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK- IS HERE
AND PRESENT. IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWO WE PASSED AB OH
EIGHT EIGHT TO PUT KINDA. WHO
ARE FACING RECORD ON AND
FINANCIAL. VETERANS BY OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. NOW FIVE
LATER. LATER THE PRETTY WILL ON
TO THIRTY FIRST AND WE'RE LESS.
WITH A DIFFERENT QUESTION AND
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO THOUSANDS
TENANTS. ON CUSP OF ALMOST. AND
HOW DO WE SUPPORT SMALLER ARE
THE CUSP OF FIVE ROOM. JUST A
DAYS AGO DID YOU JUST- CAL
PROJECT. THAT WE WILL WITNESS.
TO HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
NEW INFECTIONS. DOUBLE THE
NORMAL NUMBER OF CASES IF WE DO
NOT. EXTEND THE MORATORIUM.
EDITOR'S BEEN. THAT THE HAS
THIS FOR IMPACTED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
RENTERS. WE ARE FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE AND THE
BILLS THAT WE PASSED TODAY WILL
PROVIDE REALISTIC AND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS BY PRIORITIZING MARC.
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES AND
OFFERING SUPPORT TO LANDLORDS.
THE MAN EXTEND THE NATION
STRONG TENANT PROTECTION AND
THE TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF.
VOTING ON THESE TWO BILLS TODAY
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE BILLS
ARE PERFECT FOR THAT THE
PROBLEM IS SOLVED INSTEAD. IT
ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
ADDRESSING OUTSTANDING CONCERNS
AND TACKLE AND ALLOWS US MORE
TIME TO TACKLE THIS PRESSING
ISSUE WITHOUT FACING AN
ADDITIONAL AVALANCHE OF ISSUES.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP ON
THESE EFFORTS SO THAT COME JUNE
THIRTIETH. WE WILL BE READY TO
FURTHER PROTECT TENANTS AND
SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MITCHELL
THIS RIVAS. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY ONE ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN THE THIRTY
NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHO
HAVE BEEN HIT PARTICULARLY HARD
BY THIS PANDEMIC MY DISTRICT
HAS CONSISTENTLY EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
COVE ED INFECTIONS IN ALL OF LA
COUNTY. THE VAST MAJORITY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE THOSE WORKING
WHAT ARE CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL
JOBS THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIVINGDOUBLED AND TRIPLED UP
IN HOUSES AND APARTMENTS DUE TO
LIMITED SUPPLY AND LOW INCOMES
AND WE MUST PROTECT THEM. THEY
ARE CAUGHT BETWEEN TWO
REALITIES THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
LUCKY ENOUGH TO KEEP THEIR JOBS
MUST CONTINUE WORKING. OFTEN
EXPOSING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO THE VIRUS JUST TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
OTHERWISE IF THEY LOSE THEIR
JOB OR BECOME SICK DUE TO
COVERED THEY HAVE NO ABILITY TO
PAY THE RENT. THE BILL IS MORE
THAN JUST VOTE FOR ME THE
ACTION WE ARE TAKING TODAY IS A
HUMANITARIAN OBLIGATION WE HAVE
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS. TO
MITIGATE IMPACTS ON THOSE WHO
ARE BEING DEVASTATED
ECONOMICALLY BY THIS PANDEMIC.
I READ A REPORT YESTERDAY BY
OXFAM THAT SAID THAT THE SUPER
RICH HAVE ALREADY RECOVERED
FROM THE PANDEMIC ECONOMIC
LOSSES BUT IT COULD TAKE ARE
POOR AT DECK MORE TO RECOVER. I
ASK YOU TO STAND WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS RIVAS
MR VOEPEL. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I SUPPORT SB NINETY
ONE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
MY SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN TH
ASSEMBLY THAT THERE'S VARIOUS
CATEGORIES OTHER THE RENTERS
WITHIN THIS BILL. UTILITIES ARE
DOWN THE FOOD CHAIN HERE NOW
WITH UTILITIES WE ALL THINK
ELECTRIC AND GAS COMPANIES IN
THE BIG THE BIG GUYS. I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THERE ARE WATER DISTRICTS
AND WATER AUTHORITIES IN ALL OF
OUR- ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS AND IN
AND ALSO OTHER RURAL. DISTRICTS
MANY OF OUR WATER DISTRICTS
THAT SERVE POORER PEOPLE. ARE
UP 230% IN ARREARS FURTHER
WATER BILLS SO THE WATER
DISTRICTS STILL HAVE THE
OVERHEAD BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE INCOME SO IN THE FUTURE
WITH THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
RE DOING STIMULUS PLANS I WOULD
LIKE. MY COLLEAGUES TO THANK OF
WATER DISTRICTS AND MAYBE PUT
THEM A LITTLE BIT FURTHER UP ON
THE FOOD CHAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR VOEPEL MR
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. RISES SOMEBODY WHO HAS
BEEN BOTH A LANDLORD. AN
ATTENDANT. THE SOMEBODY THAT
GREW UP POOR. WHO'S BEEN ON
FOOD STAMPS. WATER STANDS WHAT
IT MEANS TO HAVE AN EBT CARD. I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT IS.
OVER 60% FAMILIES WHO ARE ON
ASSISTANCE. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME THAT THIS
ISN'T PERFECT. HELL MOST THE
LEGISLATION WE PASS ISN'T. BUT
WE ARE IN A DESPERATE TIME
RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLES. WE HAVE FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO GET THEIR EDT
CHECKS. THIS PROGRAM OFFERS AN
OPTION. IN TIMES OF DARKNESS.
AN OPTION THAT LANDLORDS CAN
CHOOSE IF THEY WOULD LIKE. AN
OPTION FOR TENANTS. IT'S AN
OPTION TO GET RELIEF. NOW I
LIKE MANY HAVE GREAT CONCERNS.
AS WE ASK GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO
PLEASE NOT SCREW THIS ONE UP TO.
AND I KNOW WE WILL ALL BE
WATCHING. AS WE DISCUSSED IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE YESTERDAY. WE
ASKED FOR A METRICS ON HOW THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE MEASURED.
WHAT ARE THOSE MEASUREMENTS OF
SUCCESS GOING TO BE. WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO LOOK LIKE. ARE WE
GOING TO MAKE SURE. THE WEBSITE
FOR THIS PROGRAM DOESN'T CRASH
LIKE THE OTHERS HAVE. ARE WE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CALL CENTERS. ACTUALLY WORK.
FOR OUR ELDERLY AND OTHERS.
WHEN ROLE DISTRICTS LIKE MINE
AND SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY OF EVEN HAVING
INTERNET SERVICE. WE'RE GOING
TO ENSURE THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY EQUITABLE FOR EVERYONE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU. TO HELP
ME. ENSURE THAT THIS PROGRAM
GETS DONE CORRECTLY. THAT ARE
ADMINISTRATORS. OVER THIS
PROGRAM ARE DOING THEIR JOBS.
IN THAT WE DON'T HAVE YET
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT PROGRAM THAT
FILLS THE PEOPLE THAT IT'S
DESIGNED TO SERVE. I KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT. BUT OUR PEOPLE NEED
THIS. I PRAY TO GOD THE
ADMINISTRATION GETS IT RIGHT
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS THIS KAMLAGER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TO RISE IN ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT WITH AN AYE
VOTE FOR SB NINETY ONE. YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN HERE FOR SOME
TIME AND I'M- STILL LOOKING FOR
THE PERFECT BILL THIS IS NOT
THAT BILL. BUT THE PERFECT CAN
NEVER BE THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A COUPLE OF REASONS WHY
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF STORIES COMING OUT
OF MY DISTRICT. BECAUSE OF THE
STORY OF KELLY. KELLY IS A
RENTER KELLY THE TENANTS IN THE
FIFTY FOURTH. AND SHE RENTS
FROM VERY SMALL MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS. THIS WOMAN OWNS A
SIX UNIT BUILDING. TWO OF THOSE
UNITS ARE VACANT BECAUSE OF
COVERT. AND SHE HAS CANCER THAT
SHE STRUGGLING TO MANAGE. AND
KELLY IS AFRAID. THAT IF WE
DON'T PASS THIS BILL. THERE
WILL BE NO PROTECTIONS FOR HER
LANDLORD WHO SHE LIKES. WHO
KEEPS THE RENTS LOW WHO KNOWS
THE COMMUNITY. AND THAT
LANDLORDS WILL BE FORCED. TO
SELL HER UNIT OR IT WILL BE
LOST. AND GOBBLED UP BY A
CORPORATE ENTITY. THAT OWNS
ALMOST 70% OF THE UNITS. AND
ISN'T OF THE COMMUNITY. I'M
GOING TO BE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF JANICE. WHOSE
FAMILY WAS A VERY SAID IN
DECEMBER. RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
PAY THE RENT. WELL THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED. AND IF
WE PASS THIS BILL THE MAYBE
STORIES LIKE THAT. WON'T HAPPEN.
I'M LOOKING AT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AS A YEAR OF RECOVERY AND
WE SHOULD BE MARSHALLING IN.
THE RESOURCES OF THE STATE. TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS RECOVER.AND
RENT LIKE CHILD CARE IS A BASIC
NEED FOR WORKING FAMILIES. WE
CAN PASS THE SPELL WE SHOULD
PASS THIS BILL. WE BETTER
PASSED THIS BILL. BUT AFTER
THAT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE GETTING INFORMATION
OUT TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE GETTING
OUT THE RELIEF THAT THEY
DESERVE. SO ON BEHALF OF JANICE
AND KELLY. AND THE THOUSANDS OF
OTHER FOLKS THAT LIVE IN RENTS
IN THE FIFTY FOUR. AND I TO A
RENTAL. I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MISS KAMLAGER. MISSION. ONE
MISTER WHEN ON. HERBIE FROM THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MISSION
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR ALLOW ME
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS I BELIEVE
TODAY'S BILL HAS STRUCK
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD. EFFORT TO HELP NOT ONLY
THE TENNIS. BUT ALSO THOSE
SMALL MOM AND POP LANDLORDS WHO
OWNS ONE RENTAL OR TO. LOTS OF
THESE LANDLORDS ARE NOT A BIG
CORPORATION LANDLORDS THAT OWNS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF UNITS
THESE ARE LANDLORDS. WHO BOUGHTA RENTAL TO HELP SUPPLEMENT A
RETIREMENT INCOME OR SUPPLEMENT
THE PART TIME JOB. SO PLEASE DO
UNDERSTAND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
LANDLORDS IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
BIG CORPORATE LANDLORDS. THESE
ARE THE MOM AND POP LANDLORDS
JUST LIKE THE MOM AND POP.
BUSINESSES THEY TO HAVE SUFFER.
THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY ONE THEY
HAVE GONE OUT A YEAR NOW
WITHOUT ANY INCOME. THEY ARE
ALSO TRYING TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE FOR THEIR FAMILIES AS
WELL. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR CHILDREN ARE TAKEN CARE
OF OR THEIR GRANDCHILDREN OR
TAKING CARE OF. AND IF THEY'RE
HELPING THE CHILDREN IS BECAUSE
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE POLY ADULT.
WHO LOST THEIR JOB. SO THIS IS
NOT ABOUT THE BIG CORPORATION
THAT YOU'RE ALWAYS THINKING UP
TOP A LANDLORDS. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. I ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS. ONE
THERE'S NO TIME FRAME AS FAST
AS THEY NEED TO GET THE RENTAL
SYSTEM MONEY. IS IT GONNA BE
WEEKS. ONCE WE KNOW EDT SYSTEM
OF THE GOVERNOR OF OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT WORKING WELL.
I HOPE IT'S NOT TO BE THE SAME
SYSTEM OR SIMILAR LEE RUN.
THERE'S ALSO NO LANGUAGE FOR
THE FOR THE LANDLORDS ARE
REQUIRED TO SEND TO THE
TENANTS. REGARDING THE RENTAL
SYSTEM PROGRAMS. ARE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC. THAT WOULD BE COMING
OUT TO SYSTEM LANDLORDS OR THEY
SUPPOSED TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY TO
DRAFT SOMETHING UP. AS
MENTIONED IS A SMALL MOM AND
POPS LANDLORDS. THAT'S VERY
BURDENSOME BECAUSE HIRING AN
ATTORNEY TO DRAFT. A CONTRACT
OR NOTICE. GIVE ME A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. EASILY THEY TOO DON'T
HAVE THAT KIND OF MONEY WE NEED
TO HELP THEM AND HAVE A UNIFORM.
DOCUMENT FOR THEM TO USE. WHAT
IF WHAT IF THE TENANT REFUSES
TO APPLY FOR THE SYSTEM. IS THE
LANDLORD ON THE HOOK. AND THEN
WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THE
RENTAL RELIEF. I KNOW THE BILL
IT DOES ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE
BIT BUT I THINK IT CAN GO A
LITTLE FURTHER. TO MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR FOR THE TENANT
AND LANDLORD AND THEY KNOW WHAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE. TO
RECEIVE THE FUNDS FOR THE
LANDLORDS MUST SHOW GOOD FAITH.
THAT THEY HAVE TRIED EVERY
OTHER RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS TO HELP THE TENNIS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WHAT DOES
GOOD FAITH MEAN. I THINK THAT
DEFINITION. MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
IN MY UNDERSTANDING VERSUS
YOURS FOR AN ATTORNEY. OR
SOMEBODY ELSE SO I BELIEVE THAT
IF WE HAVE SOME KIND OF
LANGUAGE SO WE CAN ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT GOOD FAITH MEAN
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL NOT
ONLY FOR THE TENANT BUT ALSO
FOR THE LANDLORD AS WELL. LAST
I KNOW THAT THERE'S THREE
DISTRIBUTION BROWN'S. IS THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE MONEY
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL OF NEED.
IF SO. HOW LONG DOES EACH ROUND
TAKE. WILL BE DAYS WEEKS MONTHS
BECAUSE THIS GOES TO ONLY SIX
MONTHS. WE DON'T HAVE TIME WE
NEED TO MOVE FAST THEY NEED THE
ASSISTANT NOW AND SO I ASK THAT
ASWE MOVE FORWARD IN LOOKING
AT THE BILL AND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT IT THANK YOU PLEASE
LOOK AT THESE AND CONSIDER AND
BE REMINDED. THAT WE NEED TO
HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND NOT
JUST ONE OVER ANOTHER BECAUSE
THEY ALL NEED HELP. WE NEED TO
GET THROUGH THIS TOGETHER. ASK
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR WHEN MR KILEY. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOT ASKING FOR A PERPETUAL
ADDICTION MOTOR MORATORIUM ON
TOP OF THE FEDERAL MORATORIUM
THAT ALREADY EXISTS
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASKING FOR THE
RIGHTS TO GET BACK TO WORK
SHORT OF THAT THERE AT LEAST
ASKING TO GET THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK RATHER THAN
HAVING TO WATCH IT LAND IN A
STATE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
WE'VE HAD ABOUT THE NATION'S
WORST UNEMPLOYMENT AND ITS MOST
DYSFUNCTIONAL. UNEMPLOYMENT
OFFICE THROUGHOUT THE LAST
YEAR. AND THIS MEASURE IS AN
EXCUSE FOR NEGLECTING THOSE
STAGGERING PROBLEMS. I AM NOT
GOING TO. ENABLE THAT BLACKED
BY VOTING FOR IT. INSTEAD I'M
GOING TO AGAIN IN FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ASSERT ITSELF AS
A CO EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT. ON MATTERS OF
CENTRAL IMPORTANCE TO THE LIVES
AND LIVELIHOODS OF THE PEOPLE
WE REPRESENT. DR WHAT. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I JUST WANT TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- I RISING
HOPE. I RISE WITH THE LITTLE
CONCERN. AND A HEALTHY DOSE OF
SKEPTICISM AND- I DON'T SAY
THAT LIGHTLY- THERE ARE A-
THIRTY COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE A POPULATION OF LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. I
REPRESENT FOUR OF THEM. ALL
THOSE COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE
TREATED A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
BIGGER COUNTY'S AGAIN GET
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE'S
OTHER A MECHANISM SUPPORT MY
SMALLER COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH EXTRA
HOOPS. NOW YESTERDAY WE HEARD
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SPECIAL SET ASIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THERE WHICH
PRESUMABLY WILL MAKE EVERYTHING
EQUAL. AND MY SO MY SKEPTICISM
COMES FROM WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE CURES ACT NGUYEN SMALLER
COUNTIES SIMPLY WEREN'T TREATED
EQUALLY. RESOURCES WENT TO
LARGER COUNTIES A LOT MORE
RESOURCES WENT TO LARGER
COUNTIES ON A BET THAT SOME OF
THOSE COUNTIES WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE OUTBREAKS OF
CORONAVIRUS THAN THEY DID WHILE
SOME OF THE SMALLER COUNTIES
LIKE. OF MY FRIEND FROM THE
DESERT DOWN THERE HAD THE
HIGHEST RATES IN THE STATE. SO
MY SKEPTICISM IS. AND I'M NOT
GOING TO APOLOGIZE. FOR
ADVOCATING FOR MY CONSTITUENTS.
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES WE OFTEN
GET SHORT SHRIFT. BUT THIS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT RURAL
COMMUNITIES THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED WHO HAVE THE BIGGEST
RISK OF EVICTION LIVE IN OUR
LARGE URBAN AREAS AS WELL. NOW
MY SKEPTICISM COMES IN PART. WE
HEARD ABOUT A NEW WEBSITES CAN
BE ROLLED OUT IN MOBILE
APPLICATIONS AND ALLOW PEOPLE
TO DO TO ACCESS THIS. WELL IF
YOU WANT TO DRIVE IN MY
DISTRICT. ABOUT HALF THE
DISTANCE FROM NORTH TO SOUTH
ABOUT A SEVEN HOUR DRIVE IN
HALF THAT DISTANCE YOU DON'T
HAVE. OU DON'T HAVE SO ACCESS.
WE FOUND OUT NINETEEN
CORONAVIRUS TIMES HERE. THAT
KIDS CAN'T GET ACCESS TO
INTERNET OUT INTO THE INTERNET
IT JUST DOESN'T EXIST. SO HOW
DO WE REACH THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE HIGHEST RISK FOR
ADDICTION HOW DO WE GET THEM
THAT INFORMATION. THESE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH
AN EXTRA HOOP TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO I'M GONNA
WATCH THIS WITH. CONCERN AND I
HOPE THOSE METRICS PROVE ME
WRONG- BUT THIS THIS VIRUS HAS
SHOWN THAT WE'VE WE'VE GOT SOME
SYSTEMIC CHALLENGES HERE IN IN
OUR SYSTEMS AND WE NEED TO
OVERCOME THEM AND I HOPE THAT
EACH CD. HAS THE BAND WITH TO
BE ABLE TO HANDLE THIS. PEOPLE
WHO ARE FACING EVICTION ARE
PROBABLY NOT. HAVING A ROBUST
BROADBAND IN THEIR HOMES THEY
MAYBE HAVE A FLIP PHONE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PEOPLE MAYBE
THEY DON'T I DON'T KNOW.
FORTUNATELY I'M NOT IN THAT
SITUATION. BUT RIGHT NOW THOSE
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NEED TO ACCESS
A SYSTEM LIKE THIS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THE INTERNET THEY CAN'T
EVEN GO TO A PUBLIC LIBRARY
BECAUSE THOSE ARE CLOSED. AND
THERE'S AND THERE'S INTERNET
ACCESS THERE AS WELL. SO MY
CONCERN IS LET'S I HOPE THAT
I'M WRONG I HOPE WE CAN GET THE
ROBUST OUT REACH THAT THE
COMMUNICATIONS HAPPEN THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED THIS
RESISTANCE CAN GET TO IT THAT
LANDLORDS. IN THESE AREAS AS
WELL WHO ALSO LIVE IN REMOTE
AEAS GET ACCESS TO THIS I HOPE
IT WORKS I REALLY DO. I VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY IN THE HOPE FOR
THAT BUT WE WILL BE WATCHING
AND WE HOPE THAT OUR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES GET JUST AS MUCH
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES AS
LARGER AREAS THAT WILL GET THE
MONEY DIRECTLY. THANK YOU. MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB NINETY ONE IS NOT
THE PERFECT SOLUTION BUT IT IS
A SOLUTION TO A DIRE PROBLEM
RENTERS ACROSS OUR STATE HAVE
BEEN OUT OF WORK THE NIGHT
ASSISTANCE FROM CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND THEN NOW IT RISK
ONCE AGAIN OF LOSING THEIR
HOUSING. SIMILARLY LANDLORDS
HAVE BEEN LEFT HOLDING THE BAG
FOR NEARLY A YEAR. NOW THE
STATE WILL ASK THEM TO ACCEPT
JUST 80% OF WHAT THEY ARE OWED.
IN MY DISTRICT WHICH IS VERY
RURAL AND LACKS INTERNET
SERVICES WELL AND MUCH OF THE
AREA. IT INCLUDES SOME OF THE
LOWEST INCOME CENSUS TRACTS IN
THE NATION. RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS ARE DEMANDING
SOLUTIONS WE MUST SUPPORT OUR
PEOPLE THE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE WHO ARE STRUGGLING IN
THESE TIMES. IN MOST OF MY
DISTRICT ALMOST 60% OF SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES ARE RENTALS. I'VE
HEARD OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FROM PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT WHO ARE SUFFERING AND
THEY NEED HELP WHEN WE CANNOT
LEAVE THEM WITHOUT HELP. WHILE
I WILL BE SUPPORTING SB NINETY
ONE TODAY- WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM WILL ACTUALLY
WORK A SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED. AND THAT IT IS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT ALL AROUND THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA NEEDS REAL
SOLUTIONS AND WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE HOUSING CRISIS. THAT
PLAGUED OUR STATE LONG BEFORE
COVE IT ARRIVED. THIS MEASURE
WILL PROVIDE SOME SHORT TERM
RELIEF BUT WILL NOT ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS THAT HAVE
MADE CALIFORNIA'S COST OF
LIVING THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION. I URGE URGE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISTER
GIBSON. IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF S. B. NINETY ONE.
MEMBERS I REPRESENT THE SIX
POOREST DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE SECOND WORST
IN TERMS OF UNEMPLOYMENT. THIS
BILL IS ESSENTIAL TO PROTECT
THE TENANTS OF ALL. INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE SUFFERING FROM THIS
EFFECT FROM THIS PANDEMIC.
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND THIS. IT'S
NOT THEIR FAULT. IT'S NOT THEIR
FAULT. IT EXTENDS EVICTION
PROTECTION UNTIL JUNE AND
CREATIVE FUN. TO HELP KEEP
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES. IN
THEIR HOMES IT PROHIBITS LATE
FEES OR RENTAL DEBT FROM CODE
NINETEEN AND HELP MAKES
LANDLORDS HOLE. I WANT TO SAY
THIS IS NOT THE END OF THIS
ISSUE. WE KNOW MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THIS SPACE MEMBERS OUR
WORK IS ONLY JUST GETTING
STARTED. MEMBERS ALLOW ME TO
SHARE. OUR BRIEF REAL STORY
WITH YOU. FROM SOMEONE IN MY
DISTRICT. SIMILAR TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT THE
FIFTY FOURTH DISTRICT TALKED
ABOUT TALKED ABOUT JANICE AND
KELLY WELL I HAVE THE
PERMISSION TO USE THE PERSON'S
NAME SOME IS GOING TO SAY JAMES
MISS JANE DOE. MS JANE DOES A
SINGLE MOTHER. OF THREE KIDS
AND SHE'S BEEN OUT OF WORK FOR
EIGHT MONTHS. DO YOU RECALL
THAT NINETEEN. SHE IS FIVE
MONTHS BEHIND ON HER RENT. IF
IT WASN'T FOR THIS ADDICTION
MORATORIUM HER FAMILY WOULD BE
FORCED ONTO THE STREETS. WE SEE
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS EVERY
DAY. ON THE STREETS THOSE
STORIES AND THOSE SPACES ARE
REAL. JUST LIKE MY SISTER JANE
DOE. IT OTHERS WHO WERE ON THE
STREET WHO ARE HOMELESS. BUT
LUCKILY FOR HER CHILDREN SHE
FOUND A NEW JOB THE NEW J. O.
B. NOW UNDER THIS BILL SHE
QUALIFIES FOR THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND HAS A CHANCE TO
LAND ON HER FEET. SHE DOESN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. NEXT MONTH
WHAT HAPPENED AROUND NEXT MONTH.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE HURTING
ACROSS THE STATE. ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY TOO MANY STORIES TO BE
TOLD. YOU IN YOUR OWN DISTRICT
HAVE SIMILAR STORIES AS WELL.
THIS BILL ISN'T THE PERFECT
BILL BUT IT KEEPS FAMILIES SAFE.
ANY GIVES FAMILIES A LIFELINE
BUT MST OF ALL IT GIVES PEOPLE
HOPE. AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO INSTILL IN TODAY THIS BILL
GIVES CALIFORNIA'S HOME SO I
STRONGLY ASK YOU FOR STRONG AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON
MISS DAVIES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. ARE
PREFERRED I OFFER THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS TO BE CONSIDERED
REGARDING THIS BILL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THE DEADLINE FOR
CITIES TO APPLY FOR THIS
DISTANCE IS FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIRST I CAN FIND ANY
APPLICATION FORMS OR LANGUAGE
DO YOU KNOW WHEN THIS IS
AVAILABLE FOR ALMOST THREE
WEEKS OUT. WHAT IS THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS GOING TO BE.
HAVE YOU WORKED WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE RENTAL
HOUSING PROVIDERS IN THE
PROCESS TO MAKE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS WORKABLE. IF
NOT WOULD YOU COMMIT TO DOING
SO AS WE MOVE FRWARD. I ASK
THAT WE ALL KEEP IN MIND THAT
MANY LANDLORDS ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES MOM AND POPS THEY
DEPEND ON THE RENT TO
SUPPLEMENT THEIR INCOME. AND
pTHAT THEY RECEIVE DOESN'T JUST
GO TO PAY THE MORTGAGE. BUT IT
ALSO COVERS INSURANCE PROPERTY
TAXES AND MAINTENANCE. BY ONLY
OFFERING THEM AN 80% RECOVERY
MANY OF THEM WILL HAVE TO HOLD
OFF AND MAINTAINING THE RENTAL
PROPERTIES WHICH COULD EASILY
BECOME A SAFETY ISSUE. TO THOSE
WERE TRYING TO PROTECT. OR
WORSE LOSE THEIR PROPERTY TO
THE BANK WHICH COULD
ULTIMATELY. DISPLACING TENANTS.
THIS BILL HAS A LOT TO OFFER
ANY OTHER THINGS THAT ARE NOT
PLEASE WITH I THINK WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP IN MIND
THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF
BOTH THE SMALL MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS IS WHAT THE TENANTS.
AND LET'S REMEMBER TO THE
REASON WHY WE'RE STANDING UP
HERE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE GOT TO
GET CALIFORNIA BACK UP AND
OPEN. THE REASON WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS IS BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE PEOPLE STILL UNEMPLOYED
YOUR SERVICE IN THE FOR YOUR
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IF WE CAN
GET THAT UP AND MOVING
HOPEFULLY JUNE TWENTIETH JUNE
THIRTY FIRST WILL BE THE LAST
STATE WILL HAVE TO ACTUALLY
EXTEND THIS SO LET'S KEEP THAT
THAT THE BIG PICTURE. THANK YOU.
AMOS DAVIES. NEVER TO BE LIKE
TO SPEAK PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES NOW. MISS CLARK
SILVA NUMBER THE CHAMBER. WE
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS IN MISTER SPEAKERS. I
RISE TODAY TO SUPPORT SB NINETY
ONE. MEMBERS A YEAR AGO AS WE
STOOD HERE ON THIS FLOOR AND
LISTEN TO OUR GOVERNOR SPEAK
ABOUT HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
AND RECOVERY WE HAD NO IDEA
THAT JUST A FEW MONTHS LATER
WE'D BE FACED WITH THE WORST
PANDEMIC WITH JOB LOSS THAT
WE'VE NEVER SEEN. AND DEATH
THAT WE'VE NEVER IMAGINED. JUST
A FEW NIGHTS AGO AS ALL OF US
COME TO SACRAMENTO TO DO OUR
WORK. WE HEARD THOSE WINDS
BLOW. WE SAW THE TEMPERATURES
DROP. AND WE SAW THAT PEOPLE
DIED ON THE STREETS RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. DIED OF
HOMELESSNESS. BECAUSE THEY HAD
NOWHERE TO GO. WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THIS BEING IN PERFECT AND
WE KNOW THE GOVERNMENT IS IN
PERFECT. WE'RE SADDENED AND
HORRIFIED BY THE EDG CLAIMS AND
FRAUD. WE'RE DEVASTATED BY THE
DEATH. AND EVEN MORE SHOCKED BY
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE WORK AND
CANNOT GO BACK TO WORK INTEL
THE VIRUS AND THE NUMBERS
DECLINE. BUT COULD NOT ACT
BECAUSE OF AN IMPERFECT BILL
WOULD MEAN. PUTTING MORE PEOPLE
INTO HOMELESSNESS. WE ALREADY
HAD AN ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND ADDING
MORE. PEOPLE TO BECOME HOMELESS
JUST ADDS AND STRETCHES OUR
GOVERNMENT EVEN FURTHER. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN EVICTED. IT TAKES MANY
MANY YEARS FOR THEM TO RECOVER
TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO HOUSING
AGAIN AND IT ALSO TAKES
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. WHETHER
IT'S STILL A SECRET ATTORNEY
WHETHER IT'S A CLEAR IN A
VACATION AND WE KNOW THAT
KEEPING THEM IN THEIR HOME IS
THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. SO I DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I WILL BE PRAYING
THAT THE SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE TO
SEEK RELIEF FOR RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS WERE WORK MUCH MORE
EFFICIENTLY THAN WE'VE SEEN
BEFORE BUT I SUPPORT SB. NINETY
ONE AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO.
THANK YOU MS CLARK SILVA MISSED
RIVAS YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
ALSO WANT TO THANK LEADERSHIP
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WHO IS INVESTED SO
MUCH TIME ON ON THIS ISSUE
IMPORTANT ISSUE. SB NINETY ONE
IS A NECESSARY MEASURE. THAT'S
NEEDED IN THIS TIME OF CRISIS.
BEFORE COVER NINETEEN THREE
POINT THREE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WERE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK. AND AS
MANY OF US KNOW ALL IT TOOK WAS
ONE. ONE EMERGENCY ROOM VISIT.
ONE DAY OF LOST WAGES ONE
UNEXPECTED COST TO JEOPARDIZE
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY RENT. THE
COUNTY MONTEREY THE LARGEST
COUNTY THAT I REPRESENT 47% OF
HOUSEHOLDS WERE RENTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. OF THOSE 47%
ABOUT HALF PAID 35% OR MORE OF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT. NOW THIS
PANDEMIC SHUT DOWNS THEY PUT
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE AND UP. A
PRECARIOUS SITUATION. MANY HAVE
LOST JOBS FACED SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCED INCOMES. THEY WORRY
THAT THEY THEIR FAMILIES COULD
END UP ON THE STREETS OR LIVING
IN CROWDED HOUSING CONDITIONS
WITH FRIENDS WITH FAMILIES
LEAVING THEM EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE THE CORONAVIRUS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
BLACK AND BROWN AREAS OF THE
STATE OUR COMMUNITIES. ARE
PARTICULARLY AT RISK. ACCORDING
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE LATINOS. WHO MAKE UP 38%
OF OUR STATE WORKFORCE. ACCOUNT
450% OF STATEWIDE JOB LOSSES
SINCE THIS PANDEMIC STARTED 50%
IF WE DO NOT EXTEND THIS
MORATORIUM. THEN WE ARE FAILING.
WE ARE FAILING TO UNDERSTAND
THE GRAVITY OF THIS SITUATION.
THE UNPREDICTABLE IN THE
VULNERABLE POSITION THAT MANY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE FACING
RIGHT NOW. AS WE'VE HEARD SB
NINETY ONE IS NOT PERFECT. BUT
IT IS GOING TO HELP PREVENT A
WAVE OF EVICTIONS AND
SUBSEQUENT HOMELESSNESS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. IT'LL PROVIDE
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO BOTH
RENTERS AND LANDLORDS AND WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE GOT TO HELP
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
COME BACK WE HAVE TO REVISIT
THIS ISSUE. I PROVIDE EVEN
FURTHER PROTECTIONS. BUT RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO TAKE ACTION. AND
AS MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE THE HUMBLING
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNING
THIS STATE INTHIS INCREDIBLY
THIS IS INCREDIBLE MOMENT THIS
UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT OF CRISIS.
AND WE'VE GOT TO STAND UP WE
GOT A VOTE LIKE IT IS. SO IT'S
HELP OUR CONSTITUENTS TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO HELP THEM STAY
HOUSED. AND PREVENT THE FURTHER
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS THAT'S WHY
I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT SB NINETY
ONE TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MYSTERY OF
US MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU- MISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN. I RISE TODAY. IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE
BECAUSE OUR LEADERSHIP HAS DONE
A REMARKABLY GOOD JOB OF
ADDRESSING THREE REAL
CHALLENGES ONE WE HAD A FAST
APPROACHING DEADLINE TO WE HAD
SOME CHALLENGING FEDERAL
RESTRICTIONS THREE WE HAD SOME
SIGNIFICANT UNKNOWNS HOW MANY
LANDLORDS WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS WHAT IS THE SIZE OF THE
PROBLEM DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES HERE TO ADDRESS THIS.
AND SO THIS IS A GOOD SOLUTION
FOR THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A GOOD SOLUTION FOR THE
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS IN MY
DISTRICT. BUT THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL SOLUTION FOR THE FARM
WORKERS IN MY DISTRICT. WHO ARE
DOUBLED AND TRIPLED UP. AND
DESPERATELY NEED TO TRY TO HAVE
SOMETHING DONE TO ADDRESS THE
DEBTS THAT THEY HAVE BUILT UP.
THERE ARE ALSO CHALLENGED BY
WORKING IN. ONE OF THE MOST
HIGH RISK OCCUPATIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RISE AND SPEAK IN FAVOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE TO ADD
MY VOICE TO THOSE ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON S.B. NINETY
ONE IT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT WE
NEED TO APPROVE A BUDGET BILL
IN JANUARY IT IS BECAUSE WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE TIME. WE
NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW. SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE EVEN
MORE FAMILIES OUT ON THE STREET
WITHOUT A HOME. THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE MANY OUT THERE NOW IN
THE RAIN AND THE WIND AND COLD
WEATHER SUGGESTS THE SIZE OF
THE PROBLEM THAT WE FACE. IN
RECENT YEARS WE ARE FOCUSED ON
ADDING TO CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
STOCK AND THAT'S GREAT. BUT IN
THE PAST YEAR WE HAVE SEEN HOW
QUICKLY SOMETHING LIKE OF IT.
CAN PUT SOMEONE WHO ALREADY HAS
A HOME. AT RISK OF LOSING IT.
TODAY'S LEGISLATION IS INTENDED
TO PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
IMMEDIATE RISK OF LOSING THEIR
HOMES BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF IT.
THEY DO NOT DESERVE TO BE OUT
ON THE STREETS. THIS WILL GIVE
THEM A FEW MORE MONTHS OF
SECURITY. WE NEED TO USE THAT
TIME TO MAKE SURE WE CAN FIND A
MORE LASTING SOLUTION. BECAUSE
THEY WON'T DESERVE HOMELESSNESS
DUE TO CODE. ANYMORE IN JULY
THAN THEY DO TODAY. LET'S PASS
THIS BILL TODAY. BUT LET US NOT
THINK THAT OUR WORK IS DONE OUR
WORK IS NOT DONE. I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER CHANG FOR THE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER REALLY
APPRECIATE THE VERY ROBUST
DEBATE CLEARLY WE AS A BODY ARE
UNIFIED AND KNOW THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
FOR ALL THE TENANTS ALL THE
LANDLORDS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW IN THE
FACE OF THIS PANDEMIC WHICH HAS
GONE ON FOR ALMOST AYEAR. I'M
STILL PRETTY SURE THAT WE HAVE
COME BACK AND THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST ACTION THAT WE ARE TAKING
IT DEMONSTRATES THAT WE AS A
BODY ARE SERIOUS ABOUT HELPING
THE THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH RENTAL
PAYMENTS IN THE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT DURING THIS VERY
CHALLENGING PANDEMIC THE PEOPLE
STATE IN THEIR HOMES WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SB NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER TANK AND WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS
OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE EYES
SEVENTY ONE DOES WIND THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL.
TO THE SENATE. WE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH NO FOR SESSION-
TRACKING SESSION MONDAY
FEBRUARY FIRST FOUR SESSION IS
AT. ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING HER NUMBER THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MS RAMOS MOVES MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY FIRST. AT ONE PM IN
THE FORM CALLS LIFTED.